hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the most famous sets of ideas in
Hegel's phenomenology of spirit occur in
paragraphs 186 to 189 this is what we
call the struggle to the death of the
battle to the death and it happens right
before and leads into the famous
master-slave dialectic that is not
actually part of that dialectic proper
so what is going on there and why what
is Hegel think that self-consciousness
is are going to inevitably clash in this
non cooperative agonistic struggle well
it's important to keep in mind here that
Hegel is not saying that this is the
case for all self-consciousness
whatsoever this happens at a very early
stage and then it's it's a you know
superseded the german word for that is
out haben right alcohol bin' we also can
translate as transcended integrated into
higher and higher structures but early
on in the phenomenology there is this
struggle to the death for the two
consciousnesses
so let's chart out how this takes place
for Hegel you notice I've got a diagram
here that we can consult to some degree
so what is going on in this he says self
consciousness is seeking the truth of
its self certainty each of the self
consciousnesses which confront each
other which run into each other are
doing so as living individual so one
living individual confronts another
living individual they're both self
consciousnesses as we've talked about
elsewhere that very nature of self
consciousness is not to simply be what
it is entirely in isolation by itself
but through another self-consciousness
and recognition is really at the core of
what we're looking for is
self-consciousness is according to Hegel
so each of them is seeking so
sort of recognition from the other and
and each of them realizes that the other
is another self who can think like them
who can act like them if I look at the
other person and say you know I'm kind
of hostile to them I bet they could be
hostile to me or I desire them perhaps
they desire me there's that mutuality
that's going on so Hegel says that
there's kind of an ambiguity here in how
the self and the other are being
understood he says what is other for
self consciousness is a none essential
negatively characterized object on the
one hand but the other is also a
self-consciousness and so it says they
are for each other like ordinary objects
independent shapes individuals submerge
in the being or immediacy of life they
confront each other as living animals
you know in each other's fields of
perception and yet at the same time they
also are for each other something deeper
than that
and you could say well why can't they
simply you know agree that they'll just
give each other recognition and maybe
build a nice Hut together in these
primitive conditions and just get along
why do they have to come into a conflict
with each other
so for Hegel this has to do with really
two things one is as he says they are
for each other shapes of consciousness
which have not accomplished the movement
of the absolute abstraction rooting out
all immediate being being purely the
negative being of self identical
consciousness they have not exposed each
other themselves to each other in the
form of pure being for self or self
consciousness and then he he follows up
this rather abstract way of talking by
saying something that's a lot easier to
relate to each indeed is certain of its
own self but not of the other and
therefore its own self certainty still
has no truth it has some grasp some
immediate grasp of who it is who I am
but the recognition that I'm getting
from the other I can't be
completely certain about what that means
only if I can abstract away all the you
know determinate things that are
confronting me the things that make me a
living being in this this case and make
the other a living being a living being
who's an individual coming from this
place this time speaking this language
with this set of desires only if I can
confront them you might say quoi human
being can i attain the truth of the
certainty that i am i am looking for and
that will be truly certain of myself I
will have attained recognition now this
entire process that's happening on my
side if I'm the self is also happening
on the side of the other and I am the
other to that self over there so both of
these cells are going to be looking at
each other in a way that sketched out
here how do we get to them seeking death
at this point so before that Hegel says
is good to dwell on according to the
notion of recognition this recognition
is only possible when each is for the
other what the other is for it only when
each in its own self through its own
action and again through the action of
the other achieves this pure abstraction
of being for self is pure self relation
so how would one do that Hegel goes on
he says this consistent I don't here we
get to the second point in showing that
I'm not attached to any particular
existence any particular design is
actually I was using any particular
being in this place in this time being
Who I am with these features this
history to attain a kind of independence
so he says not to the individuality
common to existence with such that is
not attached to life and then he says
this is happening on both sides this is
action on the part of the other and
action on
it's own part so he says insofar as it
is action of the other each seeks the
death of the other
each goes after the other and tries to
eradicate them not just threaten them
but to kill them here's where it gets
even more interesting insofar as that
the action of the self it's also at the
same time a risking of death a placing
one's own life one's own who one is into
the balance and Hegel says that what we
have here is both of these individuals
prove themselves and each other through
a life-and-death struggle he says they
must engage in this struggle why can't
they evade it well because they must
raise their certainty of being for
themselves to truth both in the case of
the other and in their own case they
need to dominate the other in a certain
sense and the ultimate domination is
through death in this case in order to
be certain of themselves now there's a
kind of paradox here right so on the one
hand but only by by throwing themselves
entirely into the breach as we say and
risking everything can they attain the
ultimate goal which is this this
fundamental recognition but on the other
hand they are themselves not just
risking death for themselves they are
also risking the death of the other what
happens if the other dies actually let's
start by considering the situation in
which both of them die if both of them
die no meaning whatsoever right as far
as these two individuals are concerned
because they're gone they did risk
everything indeed but if they both die
there is no dialectical advance there's
nobody to be certain about anything in
that case let alone have a true
certainty what if one of them dies
well you can't really get recognition
from a corpse can you we have to risk
death in this dynamic but if we actually
attain death the dynamic is over so
there's there's an interesting paradox
Akala t2 this so this is why Hegel will
say this trial by death does away with
the truth which was supposed to issue
from it and so to with the certainty of
self generally death shows that each
staked is life and he'll that have no
account both in himself and the other
but that is not for those who survived
this struggle they are transformed in
the process now Hegel does not consider
the case interestingly enough where
perhaps both of them risk death and
neither of them died instead what he's
going to talk about is one of the self
consciousnesses it's almost like a big
game of chicken in a way if you're not
familiar with chicken it's a game here
that we played in the Americas and it
can be done in a number of ways
so the archetypal way is to have two
vehicles being piloted and there they're
approaching each other at you know high
speed and they're going to have a
collision and whoever turns aside to
avoid the collision is the chicken and
the other person goes on and they get
you know the wreath and laurels and oh
you're a tough guy and that's Ernest
left and from a hollien perspective they
get to feel that they have conquered
they are the champion right and you can
do this in a number of different ways
when we talk about calling somebody's
bluff or you know escalating things
who's willing to go to the ultimate well
in in this case the ultimate is death
and so in you know these two self
consciousnesses these two living
individuals then one possibility is that
one of them caves indeed Hegel seems to
think that if neither of them cave one
of them is going to die or both of them
are going to die so he goes on and he
says death shows that each staked his
life and held it of no account
Boulton himself and the other butt is
not for those who survive the struggle
they put an end to their consciousness
in its alien setting of natural
existence that is they put an end to
themselves and are done away with as
extremes wanting to be for themselves to
have an existence of their own but with
this there vanishes from their interplay
the essential moment of splitting into
extremes the middle term collapses into
a lifeless unity they do not
reciprocally give and receive one
another back from each other consciously
but leave each other free only
undifferenced omastar slave dialectic
one of these consciousnesses loses the
game of chicken one of these
consciousnesses gives in Hegel says in
this experience self consciousness
learns that life is essential to it as
pure self consciousness when he says
life he doesn't just mean being alive he
means it's determinate life in my case
being Greg Sadler here 46 years old
about to turn 47 you know with such and
such a history all of that is is part of
my individuality my life right and I
learn the meaning the fuller meaning of
it in reality in terms I am more for
myself I understand my being for myself
through risking that life through
risking that existence now what if
somebody gives it what if somebody says
I love my life more than being a you
know pure self consciousness somebody
who can be totally assured of who and
what they are well that person is going
to become what Hegel is calling the
slave or another translation the bonds
been the connect right so he says what
happens here is that here we go both
moments are essential to the begin with
their unequal and opposed the reflection
in a unity
that been achieved they exist as two
opposed shapes of consciousness one is
the independent consciousness whose
essential nature is to be itself to be
for itself the other becomes a dependent
consciousness why dependent because it
gives in because it values its life more
than its own independence more than its
own certainty of who it is more than
recognition from the other so the one
becomes the master or the Lord the other
becomes the slave or the bondsman and
now we can move into the master-slave
dialectic
you